you
okay well it's not nearly as a late
start but let's let's do another one
line up
so maybe we could uh this is a one oh
tournament could try to take down macro
GM in the mix
alright gotta play faster and stronger
let's see we get here so much for faster
and stronger pick up the bass Queen c2
Bishop f5 Queen takes Bishop Queen takes
D scaredy-cat
maybe I should have played h6 first
maybe alright we're going here for
multiple reasons
get this Bishop trade in and I want to
have my beep on ready to rumble in case
this guy's challenge support them I'll
jump in here right now
I know preparing for be far what's that
about
that Amell flip they must whip a castle
now I could have captured the knight
[Music]
figured I just insert to check real
quick
what do we do here let's just take
take care next and then I'll take the
night I gotta just capture that night
for free
my opponents stunned their king is
without a home in trouble
it's just Castle and double on the B
file oh I didn't mean to do that
we're ready to enter Bishop is pinned I
could have also just captured the bishop
they have no time all right back to
tournament we are at two there are 71
players in this one receives in the top
here yo yo Parker Magda Naz we've played
a healthy number of games here or maybe
unhealthy that's the [ __ ] this is an
unhealthy number it's not the biggest
it's not the greatest number of games
between two players but yeah I seen I've
seen numbers in the thousands like a
thousand to 500 I guess I'll trade
LightSquared Bishop I don't think my
LightSquared Bishop is any better than
ours let's try to put a knight on d3 but
I have to resolve this tension first and
maybe circle the other one into e5 let's
go for this right now
we may just have all minor pieces
exchanged ooh did not anticipate that
move
that's a nice in-betweener that really
disrupted my coordination that made me
think that I should have gone with the
other night first I think I'm gonna be
dropping this pawn yeah
just try to stir up trouble over here
they allowed me to get some play for my
rook they could have probably squashed
that idea all together um we're going so
slow still so slow still I check
13 seconds gotta go faster
faster man they're giving me some I
don't know I don't have any time oops
don't you check I should resign that
black determine oh no good no good no
good no good that was a very timely move
see for normally that isn't a good idea
to go with c4 like that but it worked
out cuz
really mess up my structure I did not
want to end up with double D pawns so I
probably should have leaped into e5 with
my d3 nightmare that's what I should
have done alright let's get back on the
horse maintain up on on d4 and fight our
way back somehow ah come on man
alright you sack here I get your c7 pun
that's how we're going to do it bishop
f1 okay I guess we're gonna have a trade
I don't want I don't want the Queen's
off maybe I do I don't know I can't make
up my mind
Bishop d3 I have this covered of my
knight my bishop is a little
uncomfortable on h2 it's taking away my
flight square so let's get them
developed I'm going to go here so I can
recapture in target h6 Queen might be
active on a for one day let's stop that
on a restrictor clean back on h2 I might
have to play g4 hmm I guess we're going
to go at a queen trade an interesting
structure kind of get my king playing I
will be a little bit faster getting
towards the center with my King hang on
I think he's not going to be too happy
as a theme cat ignite
he's getting some activity though let's
maintain my pawn on g4 our light-square
opponents moving fast I am NOT got some
serious space over here serious space
I just want to capture
my minor pieces and then
like that move actually because I'm
crashing to now no I'm not now that
nights there man what are you talking
about now you got a time burn and
everything you got a time burn
oh this is ugly sorry I apologize
oh I'll make all the apologies at the
end of the tournament oh just a quick
I'm sorry for right now sorry for
winning like that it happens though you
know like it too bad
it's full of chess just how it works
time is a factor
quit your cryin bull chess isn't real
chess Oh bull of chess isn't real trap
that's right there he goes again
there he goes tongue-tied as usual
all right what's the bishop up to he's a
goner with a fork on top of it be a
developer you're up a rook now take that
pun got everything under control
maybe we cast a queen side there's a
better approach I shouldn't have even
allowed any of this up yeah let's just
mend my structure over here this is a
pretty nice configuration just want to
Queen trade now even if I lose a pond
let's get the cleans up all right let's
do this and how about we just I was
going to attack the rook there we go we
could do like this and then Bishop d4
should be a killer you got to take the
knight back rank mates are you out close
very close you can just take the knight
all right back to Sherman
a little cleaner of course they just
dropped the bishop there on e3 alright
there are a hundred players on the nose
I am in 23rd 16 minutes and change left
okay oh by the way edsells bu donated to
two cases there of 500 bits that I see I
only acknowledged one ooh that is a
serious case of double isolated ponds so
what do you do you target the weaknesses
to clean in the night and maybe the rook
is needed I don't think it's needed a
knight wants to be there and he clogs up
the whole Kings side now she's trying to
be removed to take the pond that will
open up some more avenues to attack
actually Queen here would have been
pretty good huh
the night even covers that square
they're realizing that now now this is
difficult to defend and that is mate
we're on the front page in there at a
cool 10-7 back from a macro GM macro 103
in this one now who else is in this one
all right clearly we have the wizard of
Baz I like that name The Wizard of Oz is
here all right so I'm exchange French
where there's a pond III Institute d4 I
guess so
the Wizard of Oz
oh let's go here I might have been a bit
of an issue they don't like having to do
that move I guarantee it they did not
like having to do that who would
alright you develop and then you get
flushed back like that
no wonder fan of that move or have no
one's a fan of having that happen to
them so what do we do here to move
forward um maybe we put the bishop here
yeah we want we got to get that night
out of here first
f5 really asking for trouble
rook takes Bishop here and then Bishop
d5
let's get that lets rule that out
okay this is a good way to get hurt what
am i doing just queen h5 alright my
queen is covering some ground I just
want to open up this dark squares this
dark squares hit the pin piece put a
knight on e3 I love it there
rook there Knight takes
clean here bishop there be nice let's
just stop the Queen from getting active
Bishop Bishop takes there seems like
it's closed to me hmm
um you should move
you should really move oh I had Queen h2
the knight is pinned I'm threatening
mate with Bishop takes g3
that's me that's a pretty cool night I
should have done that in sue that king
move maybe maybe not maybe not Queen ate
rook to h1 might have heard me I was in
a pin yeah if the rook moves then the
King would have a new square let's
challenge this guy he's in my house
challenge the pawns that on your side of
the board all right give me the bishop
give me the G file just got one step
I go to there's h4 let's throw some
ponds at the king I guess we're going to
have a clean tread
dark square controls what I want
okay.what expanding now um put a hook on
the open file ah not cool not cool not
cool mm okay I gotta I kind of untangle
a little bit I'm uncoordinated now this
night is a great bother got to shoo him
away he might not budge though night b7
being cut on the night just challenged
here I want to get it in c3 ooh
totally missed that move
I'm down upon now and I think I might
just give them a bishop for the night
maybe they kill their bishop in a way
here and there Bishop is kind of stuck
my rook is super active let's see what
kind of magic I could pull off here my
king it should be pretty active take
care there in time no no let's take upon
and now my king will be the one stopping
this pawn actually I mean I could get
him now I'm going here and then here and
now we get the King back into the ball
game flush the King back I could
actually take here at this stage
probably move just a hair faster just a
hair faster and we should get this now
three seconds is plenty all right back
to tournament where do we stand he has
not flipped up twenty nine he's 11 up 11
and change
all right let's see we get to see in the
game he's in the game now macro gather
first time playing all right you got to
get the podium land here podium land
preserve that Bishop Castle B 4 and C 5
C 5 is where we want to be huh take once
maybe I close it up now this is a
connected past pond
it's a bit scary
I want to watch over this square
actually why can I not win this pond
gonna have to show me and another pond
they have to pass ponds now
mmm he's unprotected like it wind him
soon no I just want a lot of ponds push
with check oh that one's going to hurt
on the Queen everything's falling keep
pushing up a queen they resigned that
was pretty quick oh and I think we're
going to get paired now uh he withdrew
maybe just mistakenly hit the withdraw
button
33 his number just changed oh that's the
one I need to get paired up with he's
still withdrawn I think if he wasn't
wasn't with John we would've got paired
up there wasn't meant to be
alrighty
you take me let's try to do something
against this point I could still try to
insist on it I'll hold off on castling
for a while let's control that square
let's take here and you know what I
might want to do drop my pawn here they
don't want them they don't want them oh
are you afraid of what are you scared of
all right I guess I guess we're going to
have to play over here somehow
all right let's back up I have the
better Bishop I claim better bishop
I called that a bishop
oh man okay clean trade I still the
better Bishop we're going to try to make
that work somehow
get the King to
Center keep going over here is where you
belong or do you um can I get my knight
here maybe here bishop trade and I hear
there's some static pawns now fixed
pawns let's go here they're ready to go
there with check maybe now call it that
f-five coming I guess they could push
but then I have that check this one King
and pawn ending I don't think so
probably even Stephen what am i doing
trying to land a fork to I'm not even
forking any pawns with that move um I
would have traded down on time 33 yeah
maybe there's a connection issue 33 30
26 mag denies that was the guy that I
lost to early on yeah second parent
alright so I'm for back but if he stays
withdrawn
you know maybe it's just the guy in
second thought I really need to catch to
get a couple more games in at least
Flannery is stunned by d4 alright we
have movement
out action okay there we gonna have a
clean trade and let's find out
all right first things first preserve
your dark square Bishop Rick night's
going to circle around he's heading for
hang on hang on hang on
to take some steps to anticipate this
may still hit yeah so let's go here I'm
not sure why exactly
on push push I could take out the Sun
all right
let's kind of disrupt there in a pin
[Music]
why not double careful now I'm
threatening to take and then Bishop here
the district does not like having to
defend that pond all right so this is a
problem I think this is just a one
position now because I scooped him up
there in a pin so I keep that pin for
just a moment
now can I not do this move I think
that's a good move give this check right
now now they're two pin so I get to
hammer away at that pin yet again now I
could cash out in the end I'm just up a
rook maybe better to take with the rook
and welcome more exchanges because now
I'm in a pin and then when we have 11
seconds ooh but there's a rook get rid
of that pesky Knight get rid of the
pesky knights and I'm pushing through
get over here that's me back to
tournament oh he's back in okay 37 37 33
okay spirit chaser 84 okay let's take
and strike the c5 pick it up with the
night I could have played c6 I think
already don't like my position
well for the moment my knifes defending
this point can I get away with this
where's look see one going to hurt me in
time we're going to find out and a pin
they're giving me that okay let's start
with the check
and night move let's get a flight square
and what am I doing with this my queen
is in so much trouble
Oh give me a night and I will take this
because I'm up a piece at the end
already next phase just activate my rook
get behind the past pawn and push them
my Knights are connected
hang on to him for a moment the attack
my truck I could still push
not sure why I'm doing that move my
knifes are stupid my nights are still
stupid I don't like I'm playing this
this is really bad this is really bad
where's my king gun oh this rate you're
going to lose man at this rate you're
just going to lose gum out Knights do
some damage be a fighter King a fighter
king where's the mate I'm going to pin
the only way to do it the only way to do
it he's running away
ah you goof ah how did I lose that well
I didn't lose it but it was a draw
okay slender again ah man
let's go t5 I thought I was pre moving
out I shouldn't have lost any time there
but I was I was floundering so bad in
that game so bad
could I not convert that let Chafin away
oh I was up a piece and taketh upon
also Oh fancy like a tank there though
he's defended maybe in the end it wasn't
fancy
maybe it wasn't fancy gonna go for me
I am just not moving fast
look at these Nate's rats man
fortunately have these covered Thank You
night
get rid of that rook they have backlink
issues now careful you still have back
rank issues out here close to traps
that Bishop there we go bring the paint
on f3 bring the pain
got the cleaning come on you could do it
there we go no time
tournament clock that's going to do it
knocking the podium land uh yeah I guess
I wasn't going to be able to even catch
this guy even though I have that drop
end and an early speed bump these guys
around tear 47 with fire forty thirty
two is where I'm at one forty one and
then let's go to the pages why not
been a while
two three four five six seven many pages
15 I guess with 141
okay man it has been a while for me to
even commentate these bullets but their
fun is always good games all
[Music]